des voeux 2010 9 à la verrière avec des
élus absents peut être le signe d'une
certaine tension très élus ont créé au
sein de la majorité le groupe
rassemblement des élus pour la verrière
le 12 décembre dernier
parmi ces élus l'ancien maire alain ajaj
contraint de démissionner en 2016 pour
raisons de santé et de céder son siège à
nelly du tube si secret c'est paya sur
certains sujets on estime qu on n'est
pas entendus il ya un manque de
concertation ou autre chose
voyez donc nous notre démarche allait
pas comment dirais-je on n'est pas dans
une confrontation
nous on est à constructif qu'on sera
constructive jusqu'au bout et toujours
force de proposition ce qui est sûr
c'est que soit l'âge j'en avais passé
quoique et 7 ces petites tensions qui
pèsent aujourd'hui existait voilà sur
l'argent j'avais un risque était forte
rassemblée à l'origine le conseil
municipal du 12 décembre dernier avec
une délibération concernant la nouvelle
crèche du quartier orly-parc des
divergences au sein de la majorité
concernant son emplacement qui entraîne
la création de ce groupe
sincèrement moi j'en suis donné un jeu
je prends acte de la création de ce
groupe
on va se parler et puis l'idée l'idée
quand même et et de retourner aux
élections unis parce que ce serait quand
même dommage qu'avec tout ce qui est
c'est fait depuis trente ans sur cette
ville notre opposant politique
se servent de tout ça
dans un panier pas on espère surtout du
calme que les dossier puisse avancer que
les esprits retrouve la sérénité et la
concorde pour cette nouvelle année
on prépare bien évidemment l'avenir
on a des projets on a une équipe motivée
on a plein dans vie plein d'
enthousiasme al'approche de l'élection
municipale de 2020 et ligne où tu
souhaite avoir des discussions sans
exclure de se représenter